Hohokam is a challenging game to
describe it's full of charm full of
whimsy and is more interested in being
an engaging cognitive experience over a
fast-paced Xterra T challenge in many
ways it reminds me of 2009 s flower
flower at its most basic was a game
about flying around a beautiful world
and activating things however for those
who actually played flower you know it
was so much more than that
Hohokam gave me much the same vibe both
in its play style and presentation in
Hohokam you control what is colloquially
known as the long mover a
rainbow-colored snake-like creature
which flies around the world spreading
music and joy wherever it goes its
journey spans 16 wildly different worlds
each with its own theme and set of
objectives these objectives are yours to
discover though if you pause the game a
little dude will pop up and tell you how
much progress you've made in a
particular world the long mover may need
to do battle against an angry elephant
alongside of fruit throwing monkey or do
something as simple as switching on the
lights
each world is a little different in this
regard and so for my personal favorite
has been the one you're seeing now your
overarching goal here is to shepherd all
these little people around to where they
want to go some want to ride the seesaw
some want to admire themselves in the
funhouse mirror while others still want
to hop on the roller coaster the
expressive blend of color and music on
display here is a perfect example of
Hohokam at its best it's joyous and
upbeat and a delight to explore and
explore you shall as there is no death
and ko hokum nor can you really fail in
your mission
in fact many objectives can be completed
simply by playing around in the world
and watching what happens as I said
earlier the game is more interested in
engaging your senses instead of just
your thumbs if you get hung up on a
particular task or a simply tire of the
current world you can easily hop to
another and find some
completely different all this
exploration is a solo effort however as
Hohokam has no cooperative or
multiplayer aspects to speak up if that
floats your boat you can pick up the
game on August 12th for PlayStation 3
PlayStation 4 and PlayStation Vita
the game features cross by meaning when
you buy one bridge in the game you get
the other two free as well as cross save
meaning you can quit your game and pick
up where ever you left off on any of
those three devices thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time